hi back right back right back for Jared
Neal the fight against Donald Trump is
not over yet in San Francisco's Castro
district more than a thousand people
have turned out to protest against the
future president there from the LGBTQ
community black Americans and Latinos
all minorities that Trump attack during
his election campaign you should be
ashamed of yourself you're destroying
families and lives you should be so
ashamed I hope you're happy what you've
accomplished the 34 year old spent six
weeks working as a volunteer for Hillary
Clinton's Democratic campaign in Nevada
during that time he actually lost his
normal paying job making Trump's victory
all the more frustrating Jared considers
Donald Trump's claim to want to unify
Americans a bad joke he and fellow
activist Vicki raiga said the country is
divided and there's widespread mistrust
we talked to a lot of people that were
the first time voting there were 18 19
20 years old and they were Latino and
they're the first one in their family
that's you know legally allowed to vote
and the rest of their family they were
afraid that they're going to get
deported and and it took a lot just to
get them to answer the door because they
were afraid that they would be you know
deported then there were tensions were
really high they keep asking themselves
if it's even possible to work with
Trump's Republicans yeah if if they if
they cut out all this crazy stuff you
know it's my understanding that David
Duke and the Klu Klux Klan thought that
the president Trump presidency was the
finest day of their lives that's that's
not the Republican Party I grew up with
in San Francisco and many other parts of
the country left-leaning and liberal
voters are hoping that the American
system of checks and balances will
prevent the worst from happening
and some are considering radical change
like the so-called Cal exit it's a play
off from greg's it's it's basically
showing that California we've had enough
if the rest of the country wants to be
so bigoted and so racist and sexist we
don't want to be part of it anymore we
can be self-sufficient without them
Donald Trump doesn't take office until
January of next year his critics want to
start applying pressure now in the hope
that many of his threats don't become US
policy